you've spent the last 10 years
studying owls and paranormal phenomena
and rev
surrounding owls a little more like
15 years but somewhere in 15 years well
2006 was really when it
when i started studying it
i got really active around 2009. why
owls mike
okay so that's the that's the like the
premise of that's the mystery
basically why owls uh
in the mythology of owls like the
old folklore the ancient mythology the
the wives tales the
owls seem to
so for ancient man owls could see into
the night
and and they i mean obviously ancient
man would have seen that would have
recognized that
and the mythologies have built up around
that
and not only does the owl
see into the night and fly in the
darkness
the the core of the mythologies would be
that the owl would
fly into the darkness and then return
with a message
and that's really consistent across the
world's mythologies
so if we update that to present day
you know the owl in the mythology can
travel to other realms it can travel to
other
dimensions can travel to the land of the
dead can travel to the land of the gods
can can
pass that veil in return with a message
presently in my research i'm finding
that
that parallels much of what i'm finding
so the ancient mythology is showing up
present day in real life events now if
we turn the clock back
you know 400 years and we're sitting in
a village somewhere in south dakota
and i had a powerful owl experience a
powerful mystical experience i had an
experience with an owl where i
where where it felt highly charged it
felt important
i would have had an outlet i would have
been able to go to the shaman at the
edge of the village and
sit in his teepee and talk about or
address the mystery of the owl and
and the culture would have had some way
to grasp that
we don't live in that world anymore like
our culture has a tough time
grasping the fact that owls have a rich
mythic tradition
and that it is playing out in real time
right now and people so if someone has a
real experience with an owl
they they're about two mouse clicks away
from finding me if you type
ufos owls you're gonna find me and so i
have been
getting these stories a lot of them
like once a day i get a really
good a plus story and
so your question was why owls it's a
long answer but
they owls seem to impart and
seem to hold and seem to have a
resonance
that punctuates or that
that colors these paranormal experiences
now the core of my study has been ufo
stuff
but it certainly goes all over the map
it goes to death it goes to
meditation it goes to psychedelic drugs
it goes to
shamanic initiations these are all well
understood
in the folklore that owls play a role so
that they show up in connection with
ufos is really interesting to me because
that
that overlaps these other things death
shamanic initiation
and um uh like a
psychedelic trip
and also um meditation i think i said
that yeah
so so your question why owls i wish i
had a good
simple answer i don't because i'm still
struggling with
what it may or may not mean so
how did this whole thing start for you
when did you have your first
owl experience and what what made you
become so
fascinated by owls so i'm
in 2006 i went camping with a woman
named kristen
and i was living at the time in right
next to grand teton national park and i
was working for an outdoor school and
she worked for the school too and i had
been away all summer
and now this seems really funny and i
the culture in that town
in that part of the world right next to
a national park like taking someone
camping for a first date is pretty
normal
so i kind of said you know like oh you
must have camped a lot this summer
you've been here all summer it was
it was august well excuse me it was
october when i asked her and she said no
i haven't camped at all i'm like that's
terrible let's go
camping let's go out for one night and
she said yes so we went out for one
night
and we
sat under the stars and for when we we
didn't take a tent with us we knew there
was going to be a um
the weather was going to be nice we
didn't bother taking a tent so
her and i sat as the sun was setting and
i was making dinner on a little camp
stove
and the conversation got really deep
like surprisingly deep and i remember
this is a total stranger and i'm looking
at her i'm thinking like
this is i didn't expect this depth
to this person this this this spiritual
depth to her
and at that moment an owl flew over us
and then another owl and then a third
owl
so there were three owls flying around
us as the sun was setting
and and we eventually laid our sleeping
bags down under the stars
and and the owls would still fly over us
they would fly right over our faces and
they would blot out the stars for just
one second it was so
mystical and after that camping trip i
said let's go camping again and she said
okay and so four days later we went out
for one night again
and this time in another part of the
mountains and it was colder that night
and so
and and we had a tent set up it looked
like it might rain it actually snowed
that night
and we we said let's i said let's walk
up to that hill before the sun goes down
because we can watch the sunset and
we'll it'll give us a chance to warm up
so we can climb into the tent a little
warmer so we
hiked to the top of the hill and at the
top of the hill
as the sun is setting three owls
land near us fly around us and now it
happened four days earlier
and they were kind of off in the
distance and they would kind of swoop
above
us and but this time it was they were on
the branch right next to us and
and one of these owls landed right at
our feet
and i just remember looking at her and
she had this wide-eyed expression of
just like
total astonishment and i
now what i didn't say at the time
because it was
too weird and i'm saying it now i've
sort of crossed the line i've like
totally abandoned myself to this what i
i heard a voice in my head both the
first time and the next night
i heard a voice in my head looking at
these real owls that said
this has something to do with the ufos
and after that
that those experiences like i i kind of
had felt like i had permission to ask
people have you ever had any odd
experiences with owls and i had a little
blog
excuse me i started the blog three years
later in 2009 so when i started that
blog
one of the questions i put right out
there and talked about and wrote about
was you know like hey has anyone had any
odd experiences with owls i want to hear
your stories
and what happened is i got flooded with
these stories
and so i've been archiving cataloging
trying to make sense of these stories
and it has turned into a full-time job
um not a not a so it's been rewarding in
all ways except financially it's been so
but it has been remarkably rewarding to
take on this
this this uh this research now
let me just one thing so when i i put
one of the on the first
couple of days of the blog i put the
story up with kristen that was her name
the woman that i took camping
and i and i
i got back to her after i had published
the story on the blog or posted the
story on the blog
and i got back to her i said what were
we talking about i remember we were
talking about something the very first
night
that we saw the first owls you were you
were talking about something she said oh
i remember exactly what i was talking
about
she said i was talking about i was
trying to describe
the my deepest most heartfelt definition
of what god
means to me so like that takes an
already
mystical story and and really pumps it
up into almost the transcendent so for
me
those are the kinds of ethereal clues
i'm looking for like i'm not a nuts and
bolts ufo researcher like i
i have actually gone to sites and
measured the burn marks in a yard i've
done that kind of thing
but the real stuff the real meat of it
to me
is this elusive mystical stuff that
seems to be intertwined
with the with the totality of the
[Laughter]
phenomena
i